hello and welcome to the shiki science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about the gut microbiome
and whether it can influence the
functional outcome of cancer mutations
so to be a bit more specific we're going
to talk about this recent nature
publication
the gut microbiomes which is mutant p53
from tumor-suppressive to oncogenic
so we'll begin the video by talking
about p53
and what it means by mutants p53 and
what the terms tumor-suppressive and
oncogenic actually mean
and then we'll talk about the gut
microbiome and it's localization within
the intestine just highlighting a bit
about the structure of the intestine as
well as that will become really useful
for when we then look
at what they found in this study and
i'll conclude with
my thoughts and opinions and the i guess
the overarching
takeaways from this research paper so
let's begin with p53
so p53 is interesting to me because it's
actually
the protein that i'm studying as part of
my phd project and i like to think of it
as a pretty famous protein
the reason i say this is because it's a
very highly studied protein
and one of the reasons for that is that
p53 is
the most commonly mutated gene in human
cancer
and so p53 is commonly referred to as a
tumor suppressor
and this is based on the fact that the
protein gets activated
in response to a variety of different
stresses and
p53 can then act as a transcription
factor
to activate different genes and
different responses to kind of resolve
the stress or to commit the cell to
cell death or to cellulase in essence
and then these responses are thought to
prevent the cell from
becoming cancerous and to keep
replicating in a damaged or stressed
state
so what happens then when p53 gets
mutated
well a lot of these mutations only
change one amino acid within the protein
so the structure of the protein pretty
much remains intact but it has three
potentially
different consequences the first of
which is referred to as loss of function
whereby the mutated p53 protein fails to
activate the target genes of the wild
type the
normally functional p53 that are
critical for the control of homeostasis
the second type is referred to as
dominant negative effect
and so what happens here is that the
mutated protein
might interact with a wild-type copy and
prevent the action of the wild-type
protein
and the last potential consequence is
referred to as gainer function whereby
these mutated p53 proteins
do something different that wasn't seen
before and so either by losing functions
or by gaining new functions this mutated
p53 protein is thought to be able to
drive
tumorogenesis and so as i mentioned
mutant p53
is common in human cancers and one of
these cancers
is intestinal cancers and so the
intestines are long continuous tubes
and are where most of the absorption of
nutrients and water happens
so most of the nutrients are absorbed in
the small intestine
which is directly connected to the
stomach and then from the small
intestine it passes into the large
intestine
commonly referred to as just the colon
and this is where
more of the water is absorbed but the
colon
is also where there's a greater density
of your gut microbiome
and so the gut microbiome refers to the
microorganisms that colonize the gut
and as i just mentioned they're more
abundant within the distal regions of
the gut which is your colon
and there's a continuous crosstalk
between the the microbiome and
the human host cells and this is mainly
mediated by the fact that these gut
microbiome
are playing a really important role in
breaking down different dietary fibers
within your diet
and this can be used to produce
different metabolites
that can then be useful for for
maintaining tissue homeostasis
and this is further reinforced by the
fact that perturbations of the gut
microbiome composition
has shown to be associated with various
different diseases
including obesity inflammation and
relevant for this video
cancer so what were the authors of the
study trying to achieve
well they were interested in
understanding how
mutant p53 plays a role in
driving the formation of wind-driven
intestinal cancers
and so wince is a referred to as
wind signaling is a signaling pathway
that permits growth
and is commonly upregulated within
cancer in particular
cancers of the intestine and these
cancers are typically driven by the
deletion
of either the gene casein kinase one
alpha
or by mutations within the apc gene
and so by using a mouse model whereby
either of these genes were mutated
within the guts
the authors could try and explore the
impact of having mutants p53 present as
well
to see if it really does drive further
tumor genesis
but the really interesting finding that
they report was that there seemed to be
a dichotomous effect
of the presence of mutant p53
and so they found that the mutant p53
enhanced tumor genesis in the distal gut
so the colon
but it seemed to actually counteract
tumor genesis
and show tumor suppressive functions
like the wild type p53 protein
in the proximal guts so regions of the
small intestine
and so this is really astounding because
we have the same protein
with the same mutation having different
functions
in different regions of the intestine
and so this really reinforces the
context dependency of different
mutations
but it raises the question of why why
and how is this happening
so the authors wanted to explore this
further and
they found that the mutant p53 was
actually blocking
the wind pathway in the small intestine
but then why was it not blocking it in
the large intestine as well
and so obviously there are a lot of
differences between the small intestine
and the colon the large intestine but a
major difference
is the abundance of the gut microbiome
which the authors hypothesized
could be playing a role in the effect
that they were seeing
so how can you study this well what they
did was they treated
the mice with antibiotics that actually
eradicate
the majority of the gut microbiome and
then what they saw
was by eradicating the gut microbiome
the homeostasis
of the colon improved greatly and so by
removing the gut microbiome
it seemed to alleviate this oncogenic
function of mutant p53 within the colon
so the gut microbiome is arguably
playing really important roles within
our body
so learning about its removal and having
a beneficial
impact on chemogenesis is quite
concerning so
what part of the gut microbiome was
actually causing this effect
well the gut microbiome are known to
produce a variety of different
metabolites
and by analyzing these different
metabolites the authors found
that polyphenols and in particular
gallic acid
seems to be responsible for converting
the
tumour suppressive mutants p53 into this
more oncogenic p53
seen in the colon and so i've caught a
lot of their results really short
but i think this study is really
interesting because it raises a lot of
really interesting questions
firstly it leaves us on a little bit of
a cliffhanger because
it's still unclear what the actual
mechanism of mediating this
switch between a tumor suppressive to an
oncogenic
mutant p53 is we know
from this study that gallic acid seems
to be responsible
but iscaric acid interacting p53 is
interacting with other molecules is it
interacting with
other immune cells that can then have a
secondary
indirect impact on the intestinal cells
secondly how does it impact our view of
what mutant p53 is doing in cells
initially mutant p53 has been fused as
a loss of function or gain of function
in terms of gaining oncogenic
properties which drive tumorogenesis
this study seems to show that actually
mutant p53 could be beneficial
in certain contexts and so i like the
way that this lab if you go into their
twitter thread
they have this quite entertaining image
that shows
the dr jekyll and mr hyde's analogy
for the two different versions of
mutants p53
but joking aside understanding when
mutants p53
could be beneficial or chemogenic is
important for understanding cancer
evolution
and i think this is definitely if you
know these results
are true there's definitely a paradigm
shift in understanding
what mutant p53 is capable of and it's
also
reinforces in the study how important it
is to take into account the gut
microbiome
into studies of cancer but not just
cancer other
diseases as well and what i haven't
mentioned is obviously
these studies were done in mice but the
presence of gallic acid is also seen in
humans
and they're derived from two different
bacterial strains
lactobacillus plantarum and bacillus
subtilis
and so understanding gallic acids and
its
involvement in this switch in mutant
p-53 properties
could also have therapeutic potential in
terms of identifying drugs that could
potentially
inhibit the enzymes within these
bacterial species
that enable the production of gallic
acids and it might also be the
explanation for why
cancer of the small intestine is far
less prevalent
than in the colon so given that i'm
researching p53 and also have interest
in the gut microbiome
just as my own interests
i thought this paper was really
fascinating to read and i'm gonna have
to reread it probably a couple of times
again to fully explore all of the data
that they got
um so hopefully i've been able to
explain what i can
of this paper to you and hope you have
learned something
and as always thanks for listening